Have you ever worked hard all week and
somehow ended up further behind than
when you started? You're not lazy.
You're not broken. The approach you've
been using was never going to work.
Here's the truth. Willpower is a finite
resource. Like a phone battery that
starts at 12% with no charger. Every
decision drains it. What to eat, when to
out, whether to check email. By
afternoon, you're making critical
decisions on low power mode. So what's
the answer? You build systems.
Successful people don't have more
willpower than you. They have less need
for it. Their lives are designed so
productivity is the default. You don't
rise to the level of your goals. You
fall to the level of your systems. Want
to know exactly how to build yours?